why hey everybody what's going on play
here with Beth Morosky Jason Valley
creeper in the corner and today we're
super excited for this Monday melee
because we're trying something brand new
because we're crazy we decided to hook
up this 360 camera it's called
a alley home right there and on YouTube
we've got our normal stream going but
we're also doing a VR stream so this is
you I'll put the VR stream in the body
of the thing that's right look for the
link if you have Google cardboard which
why wouldn't you here's one here's a
Google cardboard from our comic-con last
year pretty dope stick your phone in
there and click on the link that Beth is
putting in the chat and you can
experience sitting on the couch with us
with our idiot selves and play and you
can play today's video game with us
which is Game of Thrones game cuz Game
of Thrones started last night that's
right so we're super excited and thank
you to YouTube by the way for enabling
there are 360 capability and streaming
capability that's allowing us to do this
so we think this might be the very first
360 game stream it's it's possible any
research we didn't do we did your
research but yeah what's going on you
can also see if you're on the VR stream
you can see what I look at over here you
can see that's right which is kind of
great so the FDS good to see you a Reard
oh what's up well there's a delay on the
VR Riordan says but this is awesome oh
cool people are doing it hello this is
what it looks like when I crush your
head alright audio might not be for ya
so but thank you for bearing along thank
you for bearing a lot with this and you
can see our professionally made signed
by Beth Morosky can you chat stuff
bigger cuz I should wear my glasses but
I don't that's right
I feel weird looking at their bodies of
set droid said I know dude you can see
my cool shoes on
you don't like that car this is blue
exactly don't look at our bodies no one
tell us to bring up a yard of this yes
sorry
oh yeah the audio three six he's not
very good I know it's because we're
still we literally just hooked this up
you could mute the VR oh yeah that's
true that's yeah I'm cross-links and all
thank you for bearing with us by the way
thank you thank you it's pretty pretty
crazy weird figure isn't it
that's right but it's still cool this is
Gunther the penguin Oh could you move
that little thing the YouTube one over
little bit I've never felt what does
this say I've never felt so close to you
weasely well that's right how do I look
from the side you guys you get to see
the side of my terrible face good lord
we are playing today we're playing Game
of Thrones episode 1 which I've actually
played before and telltale games has a
really cool thing where they were
basically this is like
choose-your-own-adventure does that make
sense it's ridiculous lol yeah delay
sorry shady you can see into my ears
oh god this is such a bad idea exactly
what is the worst idea alright let's
pick this thing up my demand Conan do
you see the light at the other all the
audio feedback echo blood you're staring
at my ear this is - oh man the terrible
thing about VR is now people can stare
at my ear until I'm wiping the blood off
this thing game on get Jordan to
competence Allah said Jordan actually
came in to the last yeah you did right
at the end if you watch I'll send you a
link I just like you should play the
wolf among guests telltale but you know
whatever Reptar nom I will eared Aaron
style everyone's look into my ears Jesus
[Music]
you know we need here's what we need in
this game is subtitles I'm gonna say
that right now they should just when you
when you have a game that has 50
different accents of all kinds and
flavors just play subtitles make that
yeah make that the goddamn default
alright here we go here we go here we go
so did everyone see Game of Thrones last
night I didn't what should we say let
them finish tokenizing Neal Adams
perfect ooh
greetings from Germany hello kpop upset
droid is saying out of safety for
viewers who should probably disable the
ability to people host links I think we
did do that that's right are you mind
when scrolling down on the youtubes oh
yeah I think you guys can see O'Malley
for the first time on V our house
dressed like us dressed you stream this
is this is guys this is what I see all
the time hilarious he's so stressed
I'm not paying attention by the way to
anything this is super distracting it's
actually more distracting than having an
actual celebrity here yeah cuz they can
just say things I can't like looking
here ears I know cuz you know why
because it's just a giant eyeball but if
you guys look up you can see my hand
it's crazy - Poland hello Gunter get
some Blake got some blade ear action oh
man everyone's look in my ear I don't
like this Monday male 8 VR string Kaka
VR is a bunch of creeps stare at us you
can see my terrible posture yes spy
scout Oh spies God I know you're a
terrible ceiling you guys are just
joining us today for stream cocoa we are
doing a vr stream that's what this is so
youtube allows us now to youtube has
just turned on the ability for us to
stream live 360 video so we're taking
advantage of that and doing what we
think is maybe the first live game
stream and we're using the ally home
camera there you go we just oh it dot
just died which just died perfect what
would be a couple seconds our home you
have Google cardboard
got one of these bad boys go to this
link
Beth is putting in the chat click on it
and then you will be able to experience
what it's like to sit on the couch with
us and play video games it's kind of
Awesome it's gonna be the same link
O'Malley right it might be the same way
I think it's gonna change I don't have
any more large pieces of earwax sorry
everybody let them see my comment says
Balder stone so so cool says IVA thank
you it's very stressful it's extremely
this is extremely stressful
exactly we love you back IVA oh not as a
cardboard at home but also you'll be
able to watch this later on VOD video
Adam and so even if you don't have a
Google cardboard with you or you don't
have one right now you can get one later
and watch this watch this with us you
need what is that you need something
it's the alley home camera right there
that's what we're using and so Jason
O'Malley over here if you're on VR you
can see him is the guy who figured all
this out so he's a genius
it's too distracting too many screens
this verse key that's true I have to say
it is incredibly distracting I mean just
for us like it's weird yeah
like we've had people in here like we
did a we streamed with Roman reigns the
WWE Champion it was less nerve-wracking
yeah than having a giant iPad no human
that intimidates me more than this
device exactly alright we're back we're
back at 360 be ours that's right
Oh mallet when you get a chance to would
you mind moving the thing to the lower
left yes the old sorry I'm keeping
O'Malley busy today you guys I'm keeping
it keep it busy
that's right coffee this is live
hey Conan's my hero what's up Otis my
hair we're doing a VR thing today this
is you guys you're sitting on the couch
with us watch it son Bowen whoa they're
swearing like crazy we have a new link
please gonna be triple h Styx's I would
love to be Triple H ah here's a really
cool guy do you see that thing by the
way online where they did I'm just
talking this camera like it's a first
mother where they did find we're like a
little kid it was like a little kid as
well these things were is like a
make-a-wish thing and the kid was like
in the middle of the ring he was like
six I'm like beat up Triple H oh my god
it's adorable
it's a doors might upset is Triple H has
been a talk show ages the new links
should be in all the places new lakes
are all places
I try to thank you again this is we're
trying something brand new so thank you
for your patience by the way my whole
thing about these telltale games is just
to be as positive as possible I never
take the negative bait how much okay we
should go kill him and it's like let's
give him the flower you know like that's
my whole thing appeased a Abbie's - King
2014 my make-a-wish dream to meet
counter and Aaron I hope that's not no
aim higher aim higher you don't want to
meet us we're idiots we're idiots yes
burski this is we're kind of watching a
game of Thrones episode we thought it
would be fun to play Game of Thrones
today that's right
it's Game of Thrones link is not working
Syd Penn try to get we just updated
okay that's right all right will of the
kitty the new VR stream is just live so
Beth is gonna put it in the chat can I
have a flower is look at this you need
to smile is on VR because they're asking
why there are holes in the ceiling this
is our lighting grid when we did like
the Conan in Korea my live YouTube QA
they came in and put all these lights in
here Who am I gonna save Bowen save
Bowen dude just getting heavy I think
there's some backstabbing going on Oh
oh no oh that's bad that's bad let's go
Oh run away dude what are you just doing
sitting there I know now you guys can
see her usually the cameras is on this
like professional looking for yes
watch him wait I got to pay attention I
can't talk to you guys right now
[Music]
that guy's got a cool beard oh oh oh oh
oh what do I do
press and hold artsy then drag with Al
I'm doing it oh here we go your stream
is blurry probably for everyone
Oh God Oh through the head that you got
hit in the head with an arrow we're
using up all the Wi-Fi so I think it's
you can get deal you guys I'm fighting
for my life you do not want to see
essence 1080p at 9:00 in the morning
wait what is it dude oh man this is
gonna be awful
let's go go let's go yes I like sushi
don't shoot let's go let's go let's go
let's go what am i doing arty arty arty
oh oh I got shot in the eye oh I got
shot in the eye oh oh oh you guys are
screaming about broadband and pixels and
I'm fighting for my life here van we got
a monk in two with these people
Jesus Christ
okay here we go oh man all right let's
go let's go
don't shoot that one here we go up here
we go you paste a new one another niche
locked it up again boom oh yeah
thanks chaps boom do the mutton chops
cacao
Jesus Christ dude this game is insane
oh that's bad that's bad
let's go let's go let's go crawl forward
to safety
let's do it let's do it let's do it
let's do it
crow you slow if you're on VR by the way
you're getting it I do a lot of
squirming I bet you didn't realize how
much you screw me and actually do which
is a lot dodge him dodge him dot why
whoops okay
hey come dude no oh Jesus Christ
Hey oh Jesus Oh God
[Music]
Oh oh my god I can't even take this game
dude
Oh gotta save your boy oh now he's
kundur a horse don't leave him oh geez
oh geez oh boy that's oh that guy got
shot right through the mouth
oh yeah yeah boy yeah boy
ooh nice shoes blaze they can look at
our shoes finally what am i wear shoes
nowhere oh I haven't bored oh dude oh
it's on dude it's freaking on yep I got
what
grab it dude let's go let's go yeah oh
nice oh yeah whoo my blade wants to
taste blood you guys this game is really
great if you're just joining us today
we're doing we're doing our stream cocoa
game stream in VR which is this this is
you but what do we do now what do we do
now hold on I can't I can't concentrate
I can't see the shoes leaving the phone
there you go I got the shoes oh dude
that's what he's got a leak it's got a
bad leak oh I guess the tripod is
blocking your tripod talking my shoe see
on the 360 just keep them up there yeah
let's take it taking the great sword
dude
I'll do as you command my lord he will
remember that he's gonna die in two
seconds tell him tell him there's always
money in the banana stand
tell your uncles there's always money in
the banana stand yeah Oh son Oh Sonny
why did you give me your sword dude it
catches the sword like a man oh geez
well good thing he's gonna remember I
gave him my word he's dead unless he
comes back like the mountain
whoo that was just the open damn guys if
you're just joining us today we are
doing our game stream in VR that's right
if you have Google cardboard like one of
these bad boys here grab your phone hit
the link that Beth put in the chat slap
the phone in there and you can
experience what it's like to play games
with us you'll be sitting right here
hence the sign that says you I made that
thing pretty awesome that made that sign
well done so that's right if you don't
have Google cardboard you can always
watch this that video on demand later
and of course we have our normal streams
going on twitch and YouTube as well if
you don't like the whole VR thing or you
don't want to stare at my ear so it's
pretty exciting that we're really pumped
we're using the Hallie home camera today
which is great a rear D you should have
a 360 very Walker on the opposite shoe
off how some work is done that would be
cool maybe we will now that we can do
streaming in VR it's very exciting you
didn't watch Game of Thrones left I
didn't see I haven't seen Game of
Thrones last night hey Tyler K what's up
Julio seas are good to see you this
music gives me goosebumps does Nishant
kupuna the VR stream has really best
some really bad issues without here yes
we know sorry it is the first time that
we're doing this so we're trying to
figure out how we can adjust the audio
because I think I think it's I think I
talk a little loud a little out of sync
but that being said you can stare at
O'Malley over here you can see our shoes
you can see the ceiling parts of the
ceiling parts of the ceiling the parts
that we never want people to see but now
that you have better they get to see
that's right hey German South good to
see you good view
Oh Thank You super j.cole fan it was a
great first attempt we appreciate that
you know what appreciate you know I'm
gonna kiss the VI thing ready
is this gonna be weird that's what it
looks like when I'm coming in to make
out with somebody which is why it never
happens you are some farts well there we
go
thank you some things even don't change
even in VR now I can pretend I'm sitting
between you and give you a virtual hug
hey hey hey oh so double Oh true let's
look at the cart this is exciting your
first date this is some said like you
could if you go on a date anymore you
could just get one of these yeah trust
me this is way better
this favors me and you can be like Oh
like it's buffering I have to go yeah
connection bad very sure play thank you
bear ski
quality's not PR probably something lies
was it I think on the on Android in the
YouTube app you can turn on cardboard I
don't think you can on iPhone just so
you know okay cool yeah oh that guy's
got a dumb haircut he's probably a bad
guy I see that's right but the date goes
bad wouldn't the person just steal the
camera yes they would I mean you have to
use your own camera right yeah close
camera series is awesome thank you thank
you usual I thank you for today man
former maid had a really cool game
informer is a really cool interview with
me this month and that magazine if you
wanna check it out it's pretty dope
Aaron you are not funny I agree I agree
and I agree only funny looking I'm gonna
have to kill this dude oh it's too heavy
for me
did you miss me oh boy oh no wait is
that my dad oh I don't think you will
pal come get it ooh sweary
I you'll have it right in your bum
Oh oh dude come on man
you can't let this do the dumb haircut
beat us up whoa
pathetic coming from a guy with that
facial hair oh yeah oh pitch
ah fan of the axe oh the hot looks
surprised I hit him in the face come on
bucket hat what do you got what do you
got old bucket hat missed me
Oh Oh sucks for you oh yeah I don't
think so pal
sheep
boom yeah yeah you want to know how I
got these scars a giant sword lever
survival aah
did we kill him I think yeah we killed
well we chose mercy all right dude
you better not screw me
I kind of looked like who is that guy in
the boyband Backstreet Boys but his
younger brother Aaron Carter okay Aaron
Carter oh man I tell this if my dad was
bleeding out that's pretty rough
Lord you have a time love you have to
make your decision this game quickly or
else they're chosen for you but that's
okay
you know what I think it was good we
chose mercy because maybe that will help
well you know I will say like it's
Saving Private Ryan it screws him there
sure yeah but in this you know I don't
know I feel like Mercy's maybe good kids
you know what if Ben Lee I feel like the
Aaron Carter clone the guy with the dumb
hair cut his gut would be like you
killed all my guys yeah whatever
I already killed one dude how many guys
ready to kill you know everyone go watch
what a Malley's did it was crazy
yeah these music no I have not seen the
Backstreet Boys documentary but I did
see house in Nashville last week I saw
Tony Robbins documentary which is
awesome and I also saw Anthony Weiner
documentary called weird perfect amazing
I think show tempted it was incredible
can I get some kappa in the chat I know
what that means
somebody said shut up Julio Conan is not
real you guys have figured out he's a
hologram oh my god that's right that's
right no mercy Mercy's boring no yars
Donegan but that's okay we'll be back up
new technology guys that's why we're
doing we're trying it out try it out
they just by the way YouTube just
enabled this last seven days ago so we
jumped on it kill my family and we have
a new link the game is about killing
somebody said I'm looking at a wiener
right now slay okay like Skippy I mean
it's not that I don't enjoy like hours
of talking but exactly vr rules where
are the celebrities ah no celebrities
today but next week I think we're having
people come in hey man hey Jacob what's
up good to see you that's right I love
crude ecstatics gamer just says Conan
love sex game probably I mean yeah he's
perfect he's a big old perv you guys are
celebrities Thank You GJ blast this
frame is who to say once again guys if
you are just joining us we're doing a VR
thing today the stream is down at the
moment ow I am pulling apart that is
gross what oh dude
just put some maggots in there oh that's
you guys are about to see me throw up in
VR this is gonna be great
get your cardboard on get your cardboard
on and get ready for some pecans
random question how old are you how old
are you passing a lady never tells her
age that's right
same to me a lady never tells her yes
lady exactly vr barf hisses shitty what
if I just it could be like I would throw
up on a piron's the fans yeah that's
right
check this out watch this wait do we
have a new link I'm basically played to
this care for that it's only working
half of the time the guys supposed to
tell people for my uncle that's right
hello from Colombia hello Maura good to
see you I kept the Lord for us our
secret that's right I guess we'll eat
the corrupt tissue and keep the wound
clean you can see me horrified in VR Oh
fascinating
fascinating it's good of your new hobby
there's maggot farming that is actually
a thing though that in like leeches I
know help blood flow they still use that
stuff what am i doing over here well
let's go look at the lords chair let's
go look away places is bottom how do i
fast forward Henry it's live you can't
fast forward bro I'm sorry
VOD de Nicola ridiculous ridiculous
hey hey sake to Mei
that's right Conan sometimes shows up
sometimes he doesn't he hasn't been here
in a while you know what me well haven't
come next week what do you thing about
that gob
yeah well I'm coming next week guys what
is our what our our spirit animals asked
rep chard penguin O'Malley what's your
spirit al
his quail nervous quail not just any
quail guys in here what about you Beth
I'm sort of like a like a hungry raccoon
I don't trust raccoons we went over this
because a they have bandit masks do I
have to go through me every person here
I'm just gonna do this I have a snack
and they have opposable thumbs
you know what I'm saying they have
opposable thumbs so you they could fire
a gun
technically Planet of the Apes is just
gonna be Planet of the raccoons plena
raccoons is way more horrifying by the
way apes are like you know it's your fun
hello from North Korea hi from Sweden
okay why is my hair white I've seen some
horrible [ __ ] in my life yep say hi to
me okay stickers
Chewbacca's dad city and the sitting in
the Lord's chair over here in the Lord's
beheading whoa Jungle Jim mania bleh why
a penguin because it's a flightless bird
very awkward and I feel like that if a
lot of the time I do feel like a
flightless bird
it deals it lives in extreme
environments which if you live in LA
this is a pretty extreme emotional
environment great swimmers majestic
creatures mate for life
I feel like look at all this stuff good
lord this place guys Fight Club Aaron's
actually Tyler Durden that's true I do
love fighting what do you say Vegas yeah
I was in Vegas yesterday oh you were yes
doing what I went to learn about
engineering feats and I think that's why
you go to Vegas only in Vegas oh why
didn't you know what happens in Vegas
stays in Vegas
even if it's super boring even if you're
in Boulder City enjoying a night club
sandwich by Styx's thank you for showing
up
mine is lizard I'd like to lie on a rock
in the Sun all day this is Tara not do I
have to look at this stuff can I just
please stop we which 360 camera were
using we're using the alley home camera
where's that I see it there it is right
there for the viewer and yeah we're just
trying it out basically we're giving it
a shot because YouTube literally seven
days ago started they enable 360
live-streaming so we were like let's do
it we think this might be let's not test
it let's see let's not test it let's
just do it we'll do it live I feel like
I feel like this is this might be the
first lot of game stream that's ever
been done and we're glad you guys could
join us and seriously let us know what
you guys think we know the sound is not
great but again this is kind of the
first time we're doing it so yeah I feel
fine dude what do I have to do to get
out of this hellish hell I've been
putting it let's show the sword shown
the sword people keep commenting on the
ceiling yeah I know yeah I know we are
that's the first thing people do I think
when they look up I know our ceiling is
just garbage
but then these guys have put in really
cool you can see our lights which is
actually pretty awesome and we've got
some really cool if you guys are
watching this on VR you can see we've
got some really cool behind-the-scenes
photos over here and well it's some fan
art which is cool pretty awesome right
cool FINA and
you see that do I need how do I get out
of this anybody it's crazy
you can see our bins our bins of stuff
over there that's right
Aaron I'll ride it and we'll do it live
exactly can I leave now please God I
didn't have to like oh okay here comes
Julia Stiles
Jason Bowen has escaped I do say have
you seen the new Jason Bourne there's in
every trailer there's I love when
there's just somebody always goes like
that's Jason Bourne that's but that
that's Jason Bourne exactly how cold is
get in LA pretty cold the setups pretty
sweet thank you Meister Katie now you
guys can see our set up with the little
I hate this clock by the way I hate this
block is the worst clock yeah look at
that
I hate this clock and you can see yeah
this is what we look at if you guys are
we are yeah you can see what we said
would you say for people we recommend
you watch the flat stream and then you
could have the second one of you can
secondarily and kind of pan around yeah
yeah exactly
oh wait I miss talking to the hot girl
you guys blue Crocs cuz it's fuzzy
oh yeah no they're not blue clear their
house this 4br not much you surround you
there Pumas they're all blue I'm into
the shoes that are all one solid you
know us sounds like too many people dude
I got shot at you nothing happened to
you yes
Podrick Wow VR is nice is raven dark six
six seven well thank you very much it's
nice to meet his name any last words
past you asked me to return this though
I avoided a question
oops thank you of course oh no I should
have told her that he loved her but
that's a lie thanks for the info might
drop by time to tie thank you who didn't
assassin is this my uncle that's the
illigal probably he's got a kind face
code Oh dad says I can't play
single-player games I feel lonely doing
it dude that's the whole point of single
player now we have a reason to wear
pants to the streams because we usually
we don't even need to wear pants yeah
normally with snow pants yeah usually
just like all of us are just like
everyone hi Turkey open the curtain by
the way you could see this on the
regular stream too yeah yeah oh my god
it's all reveals we need to be smart be
smart Sartre wasn't actually smart
that's the thing
everyone is your uncle in this game
scissor his venture oh my god there's so
much talking dude oh I can't take all
this is hawking I can't take it
let me just stab some people in the face
let me do it put us to the torch usually
- no pants wait for this it's almost
like a freak attack [ __ ] it's true to
the wall they're sending me a little
wall stud helmet you can help if I just
like get out of twitch I really watch it
oh yeah maybe just the chest yeah my
hell imma turn to those let's just chat
chat chat away not you guys this games
oh my god what's best
well dunk is gonna remember my bravery
or whatever that gets me I'm gonna be at
the frickin wall everyone's got scars
that her face doesn't anybody like use
Neosporin in this game okay take care of
that I know it just Megan's Neil that's
what they had back then that's that's a
medieval neosporin his maggot maggot the
worst wait uncle I gotta tell you my
secret bro North Grove this game is 80%
talking it's so much talking but the
action was pretty dope
once Hogs have given the chance God's
willing some Oh God please people are
asking why their table numbers let's
talk more oh yeah will this tape it's
funny so we use this for a lot of
different shoots
all right this room is our digital
studio how to do its best this is our
digital studio and we do a lot of shoots
here we do we shoot all of our franchise
this year like I'd like to watch which
is great
YouTube series that's shot right over
there we've shot our auditions series
with the workaholics and DJ Qualls and
these people once he's known Forrest so
here we go give it a message
ooh what does that mean
this is where we shoot a lot of our
digital studio you shoot a lot of our
things here and now that you guys are
watching in VR you can see our tape
marks on the floor these are four
different shoots these are four
different setups we have so all the blue
is for a franchise we shoot the green is
is like a mark I think it's actually for
the South Korea a lot of YouTube yeah
that's right this is where the South
Korea
yeah the QA this is where we set up the
cameras and all that stuff and then back
there I don't know if you can see can
they see them VR I wonder if you can see
the orange marks back there are four I
like to watching some other stuff which
is really fun but yeah this is this is
kind of in it's weird this is just a and
as you guys look around and VR you can
see that this is just basically in the
office we've outfitted with a lighting
grid this is not supposed to be a studio
this is not to use decided it was
exactly exactly we just kind of decided
it was we made it through force of will
yes you will slide is here slide is here
we play Dark Souls 3 last week they're
not last week two weeks ago the tape is
to hide the holes in the floor sister
area but yeah
[Music]
VR is something else though pretty cool
and quite a trip around the room
thank you for we said 24 again check out
VR and if you guys have Google cardboard
throw that on you can it's like playing
with us it's like sitting here only you
don't have to smell my terrible stench
which is pretty fantastic
oh thanks where'd you get this Hot Topic
thanks a lot
oh what a crappy smile I gave I was like
the tape is to hide the bloodstains
there are no bloodstains that's right
how do you look around may may may ask
how you look around you can click and
drag around yeah or if you're watching
on a phone you can actually just take
your phone and just look around like
this it's kind of cool it's like a
magical portal or something what did I
just say magical point it's like a magic
it's like a magical portal they use this
technology like the magical portals you
go exactly exactly smoke weed everyday'
there you go or is it weapon 10 it's
like being a small child sitting next to
you yeah now a bunch of kids
see I like to be positive Oh see look at
that it's just a game
guaranteed one of these kids gets killed
in the next five minutes this is really
in the spirit of Game of Thrones
military base and it's better than this
is just again we had never done this
before we just tried to do it today so
thank you for bearing with us the next
time will be better maybe that's right
the next time we'll be trying again
that's right exactly exactly Portland
Team Coco hygiene is deplorable but
everyone's hair is amazing that's true
in this game yeah one thing they had in
the medieval times was great hair gel
yeah smart Terran let me whisper in here
all right
whisper in my ears VR fans they love the
ear cam your camp yeah you guys have VR
you can really see my ear it's pretty
great I love like just leaning in and
like doing crazy things around this
thing I gotta say it's pretty it's
interesting looks weird I'm intimidated
more invite you guys with this VR cam
than I am exactly who designed this game
this game is made by Telltale Games who
do some fantastic work they do a great
series on The Walking Dead yep they did
another standalone game called the wolf
among us which is great and they do Game
of Thrones which is fantastic telltale
games killing it can I pick up the
camera walk around the building like
ambushed Jordan in his office I can but
not now we're actually in a different
building this room is in a different
building than the where the offices are
that but we are we are surrounded let me
lick your ear go go go for it oh yeah oh
yeah we're actually in a different
building than the current offices we're
surrounded by
a bunch of people from the real yeah
that TV show the REIT who are very nice
and they just want to see Michelle Obama
what Vegas they went to see Michelle
Obama where she went Dionne was there
would know I think it was like it
Easter's oh yeah first 360 liver stream
it should be called the liver stream oh
who necessity' there's still 22 hours of
telltale games bundle left on humble but
humble bundle for fairly cheap you guys
interesting go check it out that's great
good looking out please call Jordan here
please please please what we're gonna do
is the next time we have the next time
we invite Jordan we're gonna have
something for me to do because everybody
kind of freaked out and we feel like we
kind of wasted his visit it took it like
almost two years to get to Arden in here
and then we were just like so we're
gonna figure out something that was a
true surprise you got you I've not seen
the new episode I was in May Oh spy
scout sister making a Batman telltale
game I am very excited about that
that'll be cool dude use face
moisturizer bro you did get notice reach
it what's my favorite game Eleanor
oh that's a good question there's so
many good ones what's the game I put the
most time in tools
I mean Red Dead Redemption is great
this guy's a dick roylene's a dick what
are my thoughts in the sand snakes I
have no idea what you're talking about
Beach my the ladies via in Dorne that
you me we met them like it the last the
end of like the lassies I thought the
sand stakes for Joe they poison the one
dude yes awesome love them red love um
ask O'Malley if it's possible to see
where most people are looking through
the VR cam is that possible no we can't
because everybody has their own
experience in the
are so it's we can yeah but if you guys
are watching in VR which I hope you are
sound off but where you're looking and
the cool things that are around here to
see we see this stuff every day so see
our shoes sorts of stuff wrapped arm now
my favorite video game character whoa
that's tough that's tough favorites
video game character oh man I don't know
links pretty great no that's a good I
mean I do say like I'm a Mario
quite a bit which is doesn't really get
the girls that might be dating is a game
that's true now here we go
whitehill hair and this is the only game
where I actually feel worse after
playing that's true jak and daxter Duke
Nukem is great this guy's dick I already
don't like this guy Jordan is still you
know the internet to filter his water
Bethany can you suggest a good book to
read I'm currently reading century by
corner of McCarthy it's not a real
upbeat book but it's good
I read the hair Carol drew it's the last
great book I really liked scheme called
room a game a book called remember
remember which is good Oh boom shots
fired
yeah he better remember that
this guy has a bug up his ass crazy
someone said the staff is probably
torrenting the new Game of Thrones and
that's why the Internet I mean you know
maybe not Jesus the amount of goddamn
monitors interesting oh this guy where's
the dude I'll let go you can help
improve the internet girl at the bottom
everyone join hands and let's kill this
guy Oh Julia Stiles
coming in hot she's like don't make me
call in Jason Bourne to kick your ass
Jason Bourne would just kill all these
dude that's right she set me up and I'm
knocking him down Oh
love this woman hashtag sass for days
one of the best story games I mean this
is a lot of talking but it's kind of
[Music]
send a raven please and porn exactly
[Music]
good
it's hard hard to be the guys like it's
such a bad haircut what I said we know
we like having terrible video and audio
Jason where it could be a good telltale
series I agree good turn off the camera
turn into a podcast 360 podcast that's
right look guys we're just trying to
give you something cool you know we're
using up all the internet but that's
okay it's worth it the office is out of
Internet there's yeah everyone else
who's this person I will say one problem
I have a game of Thrones it's just like
5000 characters like made of characters
just for this game they're not real
people like they are they're a house
that's in the world but they're not
actually they're not actually in the
show but I like I think like people from
the show will appear at some point I
believe baking soda baking soda
everyone's gonna die you know it to be
true this is cool guys you hear every
time
hey there you go Valley we're gonna do
it every time thank you very much that's
nice
no boy I see a coin in a book let's just
look at all this stuff I did hear this
cool thing where you're the thing where
I view if you run into George are Martin
on the street and you recognize and
they'll give you a little coin yeah with
like the house of the house of Greyjoy
or what is it Balin
but the the bail and the one with the
death octopus what am I thinking they're
failing Greyjoy's a guy good whatever
you know say what is it like working
with Conan Bradley asks amazing great
joy it's great he's the man code is just
like a normal nice guy I mean he's very
tall he smells just like a new car all
the time
whether I know what I could make omalley
why no he's like a normal cool guy
it's great already in the box what's in
the box what's in the box so many things
to look at Katie Peter play says that's
right now you see what we see this is
how we do the Monday melee or the stream
cocoa every knock suppose a it's pretty
amazing that y'all can perform all these
different streams in chance of just
three people oh there we go
nice job nice job job we just gotta get
caught good nice compliments right ask
you to say finally one finally boy
listen we're trying let's look at this
dusty old tome exactly do you think you
could come to a VRI close game or
hopefully it's great joy take a reek
pancakes or waffles
Oh pancakes dude 100% I miss pancakes
that's one of the things I miss the most
kind of smells like potatoes that's true
did I get pain every time he's we we say
he's a great boss I don't get paid
period unfortunately there's a volunteer
yeah we go to our real jobs
captain capitalism says I'm so happy
that people aren't constantly
criticizing everything you do because
every strewed my watch it's all like
kill him upgrade your magic get a
vasectomy
that's two I think this little vir thing
I think people being in the room with us
is making people nicer yeah I think it
is I think yes seeing our profiles just
does something exactly I think it's true
how many feeds is I have my tablet I
don't know what that means
Oh on this thing we have if you're
watching a VR you can see over here
we've got the YouTube and twitch let's
let a man come in and take a shower dude
damn oh oh
I feel like this dude's gonna try to
kill us
he's giving me the eye once you unload
those things a little slower I'm fine
now why don't you just take your time
just dump them all in there man yes
please hurry you're such a creep oh my
god dude
how many soaps you got in there why
don't you yeah get out of here it's not
a good time bro
or never would be a good call wait
little nosey he just wants that poontang
exactly best telltale game oh I don't
know I mean so far this one is a lot of
talking are the walking dead ones I
played were rule very tough Hey it's
Natalie dorm a she finished the whatever
marathon in less than four hours oh yeah
he's a little bird I agree chaotic
awesome I'm not telling that guy
anything hey dude I got to go up a good
stream see you later earnest what Mona
here is good I got to play that you know
I gotta say the eyes in this game are
not like the worst eyes I've ever seen
very kind milady
oh oh you're shot after many different
social media feeds do your talent did an
interview with Conan that's right when
we did the Conan Korea live YouTube Q&A
we were on periscope Facebook YouTube
twitch and I think that's it so those
are the four platforms or
I believe but yeah it was fun we had a
really good time and hopefully with you
know future travel shows we'll continue
doing those q and A's because I think
people get a big kick out
hey Gingras what's up eyebrows they got
our evil eyebrows called
ready to go guys you're just joining us
today we are doing something brand new
and very cool for today's game stream we
are doing VR game stream that's right
whoa so this this basically is you which
is why we put a sign up that says you
and if you guys have Google cardboard
like one of these bad boys right here
you can slap it on and look around and
it's just like you're sitting here
playing video you're like hanging out
[Music]
that's right that's right and you can
see people that comment together our
ceiling this is hilarious and the floor
and our shoes and now you can see Jason
O'Malley over here in the corner yes
freaking out just like sweating he's
just doing some performance art yeah
exactly pretty great but yeah and and we
and this is the first time we've ever
done it YouTube just started this
literally a week ago allowing people the
livestream 360 video so we decided to
give a shot we've never tried it before
it so far I think it's working pretty
well yeah so VF thank you for your
patience in trying this we hope you guys
like thank you for your support during
this absolutely yeah let us know what
you guys think about it which is cool
don't hang on the VR is nuts but either
way it's cool to see the studio that's
true well figure out some delay issues
and stuff quickly dude can we please do
mobile games in the future clash royale
is hot right now check it out dude I
have collateral and on my phone with me
but I have clash Royale on my phone hey
yay Kim Mackel I just want to say
absolutely left Holly was waiting for
easy steps oh thanks very much I did a
short film called Holly's waiting for
easy steps with becbennett
and Conan O'Brien and yeah it's out it's
on the Internet looks like he's in
detention
and O'Malley looks like he's in
detention oh here we go whoa here we go
look at this have the old Peter Dinklage
in later
Lena Headley grace Tyrion and Cersei so
this does weave in and out of the show
yeah just kind of cool
that's Neal that's the right call
yeah please
someone say hi to me hey Robert baller
I'm good to see you hello oh boy I know
how do I do a game with less talking
then we divvy I know I'm sorry I thought
this would be more
Queen is pleased oh boy here we go let
it go you kill them all right oh all
right coming back all right
[Laughter]
oh my god all right is your house
willing to swear fealty to your new
leaves
Roose Bolton sure
oh man see you know there's no writing
it's resurfacer see just tell me what
you want and all agree
I just want to go stab some people in
the heart please she's a new VR Lynx I'm
gladder daughters I love Peter Dinklage
by the way is my favorite just say what
you want and let me get to the fighting
Oh for god sakes oh man hey thanks
thanks I see Xabi appreciate that that's
very nice you two say it was like to
have Conor McGregor and close gamer
father hurt Conor McGregor was awesome
nicest dude ever super super cool
how the Queen's displeased he was the
man and I'm a huge MMA fan and it was
actually extremely cool to meet him and
I think even when he lost he was
gracious in defeat he talks so much crap
but then he was such a nice guy and I
was it was cool to see him like yeah
he's like I got beat up like you know so
that's that's cool I think he's a bit up
dude and it was really nice to him to
come in and I hope he comes I mean sure
I'm sure I'll come back to the show
against you
dude this is the point of telltale game
home tell you a job yeah that's well
played well played oh brother
oh my god I don't even know your
question is well the Marjorie Marjorie
sorry in the [ __ ] don't yell at me
dude haha Dinklage my boy sticking up
for me yeah right men line what if this
game that goes off the rails and sir she
just like stabs marching you're like
whoa it's what he pulls out a gun
there's very little actual gameplay huh
isn't there like a skip option I can do
this Thank You Terry
that's very kind of you to say Terrence
Tyrians the man raised an ad monster no
doubt she was but sis
Circe was still scary when she had long
hair that's true so tacky right so let
me just say we had a conversation about
the fact we were about to have a
conversation then we had a conversation
now we're having a conversation about
the conversation we just had
we're literally talking about what we
just talked about what are you
suggesting
God all right geez oh my god oh my god
oh my gosh this you might be playing the
wrong game you're looking to skip we get
it out of they talk way does somebody
just think my name is Adam that's pretty
funny oh boy these condos are written by
schland everything just James what's
this these condos are written by
shlonsky yeah exactly
wait this should not be season 1 of the
game because Tyrion has a scar Cersei
gave him and he's still cleaner whoa
interesting Godfather games I have it
how are they is that a telltale the game
I think interesting this is my choice to
play you're right Rodney you're exactly
right it's my choice that's what I get
if you're just joining us we are doing a
VR thing today which is cool we're using
the ally home camera that it is but and
yeah it's 360 VRS if you have Google
cardboard put your phone in hit the link
that Beth put in the and the chat slap
this on your face and look around and
it's just like playing with us there's a
bit of a delay but otherwise it's pretty
cool I think it actually works yeah
props to Jason O'Malley for figuring it
out yes that's right that's right and
incoming streams will probably do this
again yeah it seems like it was a pretty
cool really probably every week right
O'Malley he our schools is Terrell not
drew asked how many times I cried while
playing blood-borne tears of rage but
probably a dozen but not sadness just
rage like so angry oh my god we're just
talking I just want to like shoot
something few Game of Thrones dialogue
in 360 oh god I know too weak we only
have 10 more minutes is there any game
on here I order that just is like a
bunch of shooting and killing let's
let's jump out of here let's jump out of
here what else we got
got something where we can go kill
something true soo Gears of War for the
last 10 minutes
kill something I just need to [ __ ] I
need something to happen I need to kill
something you know what I'm saying
do you feel like a good point what's the
point of doing a slow talkie you know
it's just so slow and talk I mean it's
great it's very emotionally awesome but
I think that we're doing VR for the
first time we should maybe do a little
shooting also yep right full range of
motion there was some crazy emotion
before I will say Gears of War let's do
it the new beta is fun ooh I should try
to debate it until why we're not gonna
try to debate it right now we're gonna
play an old one
kill something mock's wants to see us
kill something and you know I hate
disappointing box that's right let's do
it single player let's do it continue
campaign I don't know where we are
let's do hardcore haven't seen that Xbox
startup in a while that's right run a
gun baby she walk is dead said we will
come down a vida Michael babe at four
seconds let's go
that's my guy
oh yeah dead dead already
already dead already dead there we go
baby
that guy with it this is gonna be a
problem
oh I'm dead already this violence feels
dude what's up lo last checkpoint let's
do this come on whoo shoot for the VR
peeps you know yeah I know you keep
saying that
[Music]
spotter on the right let's take some
cover shall we
whoa I'm getting just lit up
[Music]
you have to hit the enemy yeah yeah yeah
yeah don't worry I'm kidding no tribally
like grenades or anything no grenades oh
god what happened oh god I'm getting lit
oh that guy's gun shoots a lot of
bullets
almost got him
[Music]
isn't anyone else in my team gonna do
anything come on boy
come on here we go oh god I'm right
ahead
oh my god that was disgusting it's
called a troika stick it with a pointy
end sticking with the pointy end of the
bullet all right you know we're gonna do
we're gonna we're gonna make this little
easier because who wants to see this not
me stream content on yep yep yep yep yep
yep yep all right I guess we can't make
it less two less hard okey-dokey
well I tried to make it easier on myself
they keep telling me kill count three
Jesus Salas
this is I have to check I can't um this
is embarrassing I need to change the
setting this is horrible
this is so envy I'm getting embarrassed
in VR this is the worst they can see the
blush start your eyes I know let's do it
cash so casual you guys look at how
embarrassed I am get to the building on
the right go right oh the doorway to the
right I see well I should have been I
should have been
yeah let's take a long time all right
here we go
oh yeah you said that are we going now
oh boy oh boy
[Music]
getting lit up oh there's a guy right
there campfire death count five already
yep Oh bless us s judging by this game
George RR Martin's give it up can I run
faster or no there's no furniture
oh yeah no don't furniture fortunately
we've got a lot of tomato sauce Thank
You Ellen
all right let's go
Oh cake the door kick the door kick the
door bro let's go let's go here we go
here we go oh now you're in trouble well
well well what do we have here how do I
know goes how do I throw the grenades
anybody now
[Music]
really use a grenade throwing after you
throw those grenades B no max no y no no
it's got to be one of the bumpers right
yeah how's that feel
all right let's go here we go
locusts coming through hate them locusts
gentlemen get on and drink it let's go
light them up light him up let him up Oh
No
light them up light em up light them up
light him up let him up oh I do love me
a big old gun dude this is the greatest
game of Thrones episode ever
just like butter
dead
oh yeah I love it when they pop up and
just into a hail of bullets yeah Oh
how's this for PR oh man that was
awesome whoa what that look is
reinforcements where what where where
where oh here we go no worries I want to
know how to throw a grenade oh I have
other guns what else oh I see oh I have
to switch to it there well here's the
dragon sex we're on a different game now
yeah so where is the dragons and Dragon
sex is coming dragon sex is coming here
we go let's kick open this door it's
already open seems aggressive hey keys
that make you walk
Dexter this is Dexter Morgan this is the
very first Gears of War it's a classic
it's a classic baby OMG says Casey kick
it open we killed the cam alright by 360
it's been it's been a ride that's right
you can also watch the 360 video on
demand at any time oh boy this looks
very bad oh that's not good that's not
good
you can watch the 360 VR video on-demand
at anytime at youtube.com slash Team
Coco so if you don't have why don't I
feel like I'm gonna be up here near this
fountain and just as they all from
raging in here they come
whoops whoops
blew myself up just two legs two legs
we're left guys I think it's good to do
it for today today's uh stream Coco
Monde immediately thank you all for
joining us we hope you enjoyed our
little their VR experiment today it was
really fun again grab yourself some
Google cardboard and you can go back and
watch it and it is just like sitting on
the couch and playing with us pretty
great and you can look around and see
all sorts of cool stuff and we'll be
doing this in the weeks to come for sure
thank you all for joining us
Weapon X Chewbacca's dad hello star gren
64 Batman 37 27 Terra not Katie plays
Gingras elgran David members Chewbacca's
dad see you guys later we'll see you
guys all next week thank you for joining
us see you later
you